[Música]
comenzamos una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros sigue sumido en una ola de
violencia desde el golpe de estado
militar del pasado primero de febrero y
desde entonces las protestas a favor de
la democracia han sido reprimidas
dejando centenares de civiles muertos y
miles de detenidos incluida su ex líder
han shan su chip nuestro programa
recurrió a los archivos para comprender
mejor la situación actual en septiembre
de 2013 nuestro reportero en ese
entonces sin el payán se reunió con los
actores de esa transición democrática en
ese momento am sanssouci apenas
regresaba a la cena política y un viento
de esperanza llegaba a mí al mar pero
también era el comienzo de una fase de
compromiso con el antiguo enemigo
militar un periodo que ya terminó para
entender lo que pasa hoy los invitamos a
ver un reportaje realizado hace 8 años
esta es la historia
[Música]
una gran retoma de las actividades
parlamentarias versión birmana estos
altos funcionarios son todos diputados
en esta nueva me han mar en plena
transición democrática diputados y
electos no aquí todo es nuevo como la
presencia de opositores aunque son pocos
algunos de ellos ya son muy conocidos el
25 por ciento de los cargos del
parlamento están reservados para los
soldados quienes son nombrados por su
jefe los militares aquí se sienten como
en casa sí está bien está bien la
democracia los soldados tienen el deber
de respetar la voluntad del pueblo
decidimos trabajar de la mano con todos
los partidos para que el país se
desarrolle bajo la armonía religiosa y
ateneo creado
pero qué será de ustedes si la oposición
toma el poder eso está por verse es
difícil saberlo
estamos en naypyidaw literalmente el
hogar de los reyes la guarida del poder
una capital fantasma de siete mil
kilómetros cuadrados lejos de todo sino
un centro pero dividida en sectores
sector de los ministerios de las
residencias del ejército todos los
funcionarios y los electos tienen la
obligación de residir aquí si usted es
presidenta algún día escogerá una
capital menos aburrida que naypyidaw es
una pregunta un poco prematura aún san
suu kyi premio nobel de paz icono pro
democrático ya no oculta sus ambiciones
presidenciales para velar por el destino
de un país en plena transformación
pero no piensa que es prematuro hablar
de democracia en este país
creo que vivir en una democracia nunca
es prematuro para nadie piensa que
pronto el color dominante aquí ya no
será el verde de los uniformes sino el
color de su partido no creo que sea
posible reducir un parlamento a unos
colores sino más bien a lo que podamos
hacer por el bien del país respuestas
lapidarias a toda marcha ese es el nuevo
método de un samsung chivo después de
más de 15 años transcurridos en secreto
aislada del mundo la heroína mi hermana
ahora es libre libre pero muy prudente
como si sólo fuera una libertad vigilada
o condicional
por ahora la oposición ocupa tan sólo el
6% de los 660 escaños del parlamento
todos los demás están ocupados por los
militares y por los tránsfugas del
antiguo régimen de 46 ministros 37
provienen del tatmadaw el ejército
siempre el ejército pero la consigna y
pido es la reconciliación nacional
aquí no hay enemigos no hay pasado sólo
un futuro común
de unidad
creo que aún son sus y tiene un
verdadero amor por la patria y eso la
convierte en una verdadera mujer
política
es cierto que cambió su discurso cambió
mi de megamall y tu nena y demás ese que
te ahora estamos unidos ella y nosotros
en este amor patriota que de sara
tommasi el cairo jon equivale si todo el
mundo cambio con estos cientos de
visitantes de todos los antiguos
milicianos hoy oficialmente simples
miembros del partido en el poder la liga
nacional para la democracia también
tiene derecho a sus visitantes un viejo
compañero de ruta de aún san suu kyi
viajó hasta nacido encargado de su
protección vivió con ella varios años de
reclusión
lo que veo aquí no es una democracia
estas personas no han sido todas
elegidas democráticamente
pero es una época de compromiso por
ahora hay que aceptarlo
es en esta extraña capital fortificada
donde se juega el destino del país
una ciudad construida en medio de la
selva donde los jefes de la antigua
junta se jubilan silenciosamente
en los puertos del parlament o se
regresa a la realidad de mi andar
esta avenida está reservada para las
personas importantes por eso es grande
este es mi trabajo
estos dos hermanos también son
residentes de naypyidaw pero ellos y su
familia sólo tienen derecho a una choza
sin agua ni electricidad
sus padres hacen parte de los cientos de
miles de birmanos que construyeron la
nueva capital
pero estoy aquí hace cinco años no
tenemos dinero para irnos y las casas de
ladrillo están reservadas únicamente
para los empleados del gobierno no para
nosotros
la otra cara de la moneda de la ciudad
de los reyes está poblada por estos
excluidos
ciudadanos de segundo orden
cae la noche sobre nacido aquí todo está
organizado planificado los diputados son
ubicados y agrupados por color político
la oposición y sus pocos 43 electos sólo
ocupan una pequeña sección por ahora
buenas noches tío me voy regreso a
rangún todo está bien aquí este diputado
es un veterano de la lucha pro
democrática un incondicional de aung san
suu sí por supuesto que hay un culto a
la personalidad alrededor de ella pero
qué opción tenemos fue necesario esperar
60 años desde la independencia para
tener una líder como ella yo soy mayor y
más experimentado que ella pero ella es
quien debe dirigirnos
yo obedezco sus órdenes
y de siempre
segundo día de sesión parlamentaria hoy
quinto un el ex guardaespaldas de aussa
succi espera el reencuentro con la
opositora a la que no ve desde hace diez
años estoy seguro de que ella logrará
convencer a los militares de sus buenas
intenciones no logrará terminarán por
formarse detrás de ella hasta los más
conservadores muchos piensan que aún
sanssouci saldrá victoriosa de la gran
transferencia de poder que está en juego
en las más altas esferas birmanas pero
todavía hay muchos obstáculos y se
percibe muy poca preocupación entre los
hombres del antiguo régimen este
periodista tiene una larga carrera de 30
años en la prensa de estado
juega lo hay dos protagonistas aquí los
militares y vamos a su si está bien que
se vivía en el trabajo estoy a favor
al año por ello favorece y que piensa
usted
a mí también me parece que es perfecto
así
mouse ya es empleado del ministerio de
la información
por supuesto cubre la actualidad
parlamentaria pero también es él quien
expide las acreditaciones de todos sus
compañeros
de su trabajo qué diferencia hay entre
ahora y antes
antes había muchos menos periodistas
ahora se puede discutir hay intercambios
[Música]
en el parlamento aún sanssouci nunca se
desplaza sin su séquito
nuevo método nuevos amigos y también
nueva guardia cercana
esto interesante la sesión de hoy sí
estuvo bien
este joven diputado es uno de los
raperos más famosos de mi hermano en el
pasado estas canciones los llevaron a la
cárcel hoy más serio su proximidad con
av sanssouci le abrió las puertas de la
asamblea sabe es creyendo sinceramente
en la democracia y en los derechos
humanos cómo se logra superar las
reticencias sofom its
bueno a veces sé que para mí es un poco
difícil pero siempre logró seguir
adelante y efectivamente parece que la
célebre opositora también quiere seguir
adelante pero a qué precio entre más
parece acercarse al poder más se separa
al mismo tiempo de sus antiguos amigos y
de la base de su partido por no decir de
su país en rangún no nos encontramos con
uno íntimo el fundó con ella la liga
nacional para la democracia fue el más
célebre y el más antiguo prisionero
político del país
lo que pienso es que ella debería
mantenernos informados a nosotros el
partido de sus intenciones de lo que
está pensando de la dirección que va a
tomar ahora no hay casi nadie en su
círculo cercano que discuta con ella que
se atreva a hablarle
ese es el problema
de regreso al lugar sagrado de la
oposición el cuartel general histórico
de la liga nacional para la democracia
en la calle yo en honda en el corazón de
rango
no somos rivales ella y yo no tomamos
caminos opuestos
ella me considera un miembro de la vieja
guardia y yo siempre consideraré que
ella debe ser la jefa suprema del
partido bueno
no hay nada más que añadir suprimida
muchos de sus allegados ya no le
reconocen
como si hubiera dos a un sándwich y en
1989 ella era muy directa hablaba sin
contenerse y con una gran franqueza no
dudaba en criticar a las autoridades y
al ejército
hoy en día se la siente un poco más
altiva muy reservada y sobre todo se
volvió fría lo que hay que notar es que
el ejército fue el que mejor jugó sus
cartas los militares no perdieron nada
al contrario se posicionaron en segundo
plano y ahora quien habla sobre los
militares se habla sobre las elecciones
en 2015 sobre la enmienda a la
constitución sobre aún sanssouci y sobre
el proceso de paz así el ejército la
institución más poderosa del país
simplemente salió del radar es el último
día de sesión del parlamento en haití de
las labores de los diputados se
retomarán en unos meses
a usan sus chips se preparan para
regresar a rangún en unos días estará de
nuevo en europa como embajadora de la
primavera democrática birmana puedo
preguntarle qué cambio en usted
es realmente la pregunta más extraña que
me han hecho cómo quiere que yo misma
sepa si también me refiero a si cambió
su posición el cambio bueno ahora tengo
un cargo oficial en el parlamento
mientras que antes no lo tenía ese es el
tipo de cambios superficiales que
vivimos hoy en día pero que le contesta
quienes afirman que usted cambio de
estrategias que cambió su manera de ver
el aire le corresponde a usted decidir
si mi estrategia cambio o no aún son
such y parte hacia su destino mientras
el futuro de mianmar se abre ante un
periodo inédito pero frágil hecho de
compromisos y de misterio después de
tantos años de lucha y sacrificios
nadie cambio ni ella ni nosotros somos
los mismos con las mismas convicciones
nunca tuvimos nada que reprocharle a los
militares y eso es lo que está encima
quintón el exguardaespaldas soñaba con
retomar el contacto con un sándwich y
con hablarle sobre los buenos viejos
tiempos sobre sus proyectos como antes
el reencuentro no tendrá lugar
estos años de lucha fueron nuestra
decisión muy muy buena base de cofar
nadie nos pidió que nos sacrificaremos
del ix nunca
lo que hicimos lo hicimos por nuestro
país asumo toda la responsabilidad por
mis actos y por mis decisiones
[Música]
así es
aún son sutiles desde hace más de 25
años la heroína del pueblo birmano
pero por cuánto tiempo más porque la
trampa de naypyidaw podría cerrarse
sobre ella y sobre las esperanzas de una
nación
gracias por estar con nosotros en este
reportaje recuerden que pueden ver esta
emisión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web más 24 punto com hasta la
próxima semana
[Música]